derrière cette porte se cache un nouveau
chroniqueur et oui ça y est ils
intègrent une équipe de choix au poste
ramant il n'a pas toute sa tête
donc il est il est derrière essayer de
trouver qui rejoint l'équipe de touche
pas à mon poste et nos femmes
est ce que c'est une femme non je joue
vraiment je peux vous dire que c'est pas
du tout une femme non parce que c'est un
homme
[Rires]
je prends la chine brown de la table on
a déjà isabelle en plus des mises à 30
ans qu'est ce que vous disiez ce qui
l'est moins 30 ans croyez vraiment que
je demande la carte d'identité quand les
gens qui les gênent
est ce que les gens et les jeunes ah
c'est pas une vieille personne comme
gérard louvin non ces agents un chanteur
c'est un chanteur non être il est beau
moi je le trouve très beau connais bien
est ce qu'il est acteur c'était mal de
me répéter derrière merci ya l'autre
derrière ce qu'il est acteur et vous
mettez un kilo de tomates comédiens oui
mais bien à la télé les bienvenus telle
est oui et elles seront non ça c'est pas
sa qualité danse avec les stars
il a fait danse avec les stars n'ont pas
d'amis ici déjà oui la libye des slips
[Rires]
le héros de séries oui et sympathique et
c'est un des plus sympathiques des
drôles oui sur le service public
non alors qu'à madame tf1 non c'est pas
que valable tf1 attend mac ou oui
victoria avril mais non
[Applaudissements]
on cherche à nouveau chroniqueur
quintais grande équipe ne touche pas à
mon pote verde est ce qu'il écrit des
livres non et non viendra d'un grand
champion qu'est ce qui est arrivé à yann
bensetti à on aimerait bien aussi ryan
dont le brassage qui nous regardent tous
les soirs c'est pas pareil là c'est ça
le rend attachant 4me combal arnaud
ducret dorpe arnaud ducret alors ans qui
rejoint l'équipe de touche pas à mon
poste il ya en plein succès en france
oui oui les fins oui ben je souhaite
plein succès voir le soir oui le soir on
aime beaucoup beaucoup non bonjour voila
c'est qu'ils ont sans doute n'at il sa
double vie ont rejoint l'équipe la
toussaint
tiens
[Applaudissements]
alors et dans les films américains on a
toujours l'impression qu'ils à morgan
freeman même quand il n'est pas le
mongol a
[Applaudissements]
oui
enfin tout le monde excusez moi tout ça
pendant des heures que je sors de
tournage
ouais j'ai pris mon vélo je suis arrivé
direct et j'ai fait partie des excuses
en syrie non mais je sais c'est demain
toi on n'est pas maître ou bien on est
mardi
mardi j'ai passé j'ai pas de cachet pour
tous les niveaux pas de cacher je passe
peut faire quelque chose pour les fixes
et j'ai grillé un feu tout est inquiète
pas d'accord bon vent à thomas
[Applaudissements]
les syndicats qui se déclinera et tout
ça viala le mas de mingue alors dommage
bien à leurs ados marc webb demain je
serai la joie est d'accord je vous parle
alors je peux ouais merci
c'est le seul gain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]